when it comes to minimalism and
simplifying your life i would argue that
just as important as getting rid of the
excess and getting rid of those items
that no longer serve you or add value to
your life is watching those things that
you bring into your home so today i'm
going to share with you 25 items that i
no longer buy but before i begin if you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up and help support my channel if not by
all means thumbs it down but please give
me some feedback in the comments so that
i know what to work on all right first
one is candles i used to be an addict
when it came to candles i had all sorts
of different colors in different scents
and different sizes problem is that a
lot of those things are toxic and so i
have stopped using them i got rid of
some of them now i only have a couple
because sometimes the power does go out
here in our home it's actually not a
matter of if it's a matter of when it
happens on a yearly basis we have lots
of trees and storms in wintertime so i
kept a couple of them just for that
purpose but otherwise it's not something
that i purchase anymore organization
containers this is one that i think is
so easy to fall into a trap because when
you're trying to declutter and organize
your home it can be so easy to get into
the habit of buying all sorts of
containers and baskets that you don't
ever really even have a use for now i
did purchase a large set of organization
containers for our pantry but then i
found myself buying all sorts of
decorative baskets that i had no use for
and then because i didn't have a use
fork i felt like i need something to put
inside it and so that can be a really
tricky thing to fall into so make sure
that if you buy some storage containers
you know specifically what you're going
to put inside them otherwise if you go
to a store and see a pretty organization
bin but have nothing to put inside it
you don't need it next up is home decor
and seasonal decor i used to be a big
addict when it came to this i'd watch
all the home renaults and i'd want to
decorate my home a different way and get
different colored pillows and throw
blankets and all sorts of things that
i'd have to change out with the seasons
i no longer do any of that the only
season or holiday that we do decorate
for is christmas but everything that we
have for it including our nativity scene
basically fits in this little box and
then our tree and that's it number four
i'm classifying as one item but it's
actually a huge category of items i mean
we could name this a 100 things i no
longer buy and this is disposables i
actually have two videos on reusable
alternatives to disposable items so i
won't really get into a lot of detail on
that but basically i have eliminated a
lot of disposable items in our home
things like a dish sponge oil spray
bottle menstrual pads and menstrual cups
reusable mop pads for our mops things
like that if there's a reusable option
for it i am opting for that because even
though i might spend a little bit of
money up front i don't have to
repurchase those items anymore so it
saves me money it saves me space and it
saves me time from having to go to the
store back and forth to purchase these
items again and again number five is
experimental makeup or skincare my
skincare is very minimal i have
hyaluronic acid i have a coconut oil and
i think that's about it and as far as my
makeup goes everything that i have fits
in one little makeup pouch i have one of
everything and when i do want to
experiment and get something new i
usually wait till one runs out and then
i buy the other to try it out number six
is nail polish i used to be very big on
nail polish i had all sorts of different
colors and i always have designs on them
and it was a little bit difficult to get
rid of in the beginning but i'm totally
used to it by now i don't think that
anybody really cares or even notices
number seven can be incredibly difficult
in the beginning is candy sodas and fast
food i've talked a lot about my eating
habits in other videos but i know from
personal experience that cravings go
away depending on the things that you
eat your taste buds actually are changed
throughout your life is something that i
had learned back when i was in high
school i was huge on sodas and i decided
that i was going to get rid of them and
i quit cold turkey and that was hard and
then a month later i didn't really crave
them anymore and so in knowing that if i
was eating more veggies i began to crave
more veggies for me the better i eat the
more i crave those types of foods number
eight essence for the home scented
really anything like even lotions and
things like that can be really toxic for
you because they have endocrine
disruptors they harm your hormone
balance and so i don't have any more of
these items in the home if i do want the
home to smell extra fresh then what i'll
do is i'll wash our linens with some
drops of essential oils and that's it
number nine is fabric softener and
drying sheets i don't know i just don't
think that they're really necessary i
haven't purchased them in years and our
clothes are doing just fine number 10 is
colored undergarments i am definitely a
plain jane when it comes to this and
have all black everything because of a
concept called decision fatigue
basically what i want to do is reduce
all of the types of decisions that i
have to make in a day so that i make
better decisions for the things that
matter most number 11 is uncomfortable
shoes i was definitely one that had the
three inch and above heels because even
though they were uncomfortable i didn't
care i wanted to look good but now i'm
just one that really prioritizes comfort
so much more i do have one pair of black
heels that i find to be very comfortable
and versatile and that is all that i
need phone apps games and music i have
spotify so i don't ever purchase music
and when it comes to apps and games and
things like that i just find that it's
not a necessary expense now i do plan on
homeschooling and so i think that at
some point i will purchase certain apps
for things that i can't teach so for
example like piano lessons and things
like that i think the apps can be very
helpful but towards something that's
educational then i'm okay with
purchasing otherwise for entertainment
it's not for me suggested sale items
those are those sneaky items that are
right by the register when you're about
to purchase something you didn't intend
to purchase it you didn't go in there
thinking that you were gonna buy it so
you don't really need it number 14 is
shaving creams and depilatory creams
when it comes to shaving i just
basically use soap and follow up with
coconut oil and as far as depilatory
creams they are just toxic for your body
there's definitely not something that
you want to be putting on your skin
because your skin is the largest organ
of your body and it absorbs things so no
more depilatory creams for me in terms
of actually shaving my eczema has gotten
a lot better since i tried the keto diet
and so now i have a safety razor that i
purchased for like twenty dollars and
then a pack of a hundred blades that
basically i can shave for an entire year
for under ten dollars and all those
other things are unnecessary number
fifteen is notebooks you might not be
one of these individuals but i am a
sucker for notebooks and so now i have
decided i would limit to myself to only
purchasing a notebook when i need one no
matter how pretty the cover is number 16
is exercise equipment or clothes for
things that i have yet to start doing
but plan on doing them later someday
what i found is that at least for me
most of the time i never ended up doing
those things and i just have the expense
that would make me feel more guilty that
would make me feel less likely to do it
and so it was just not a healthy cycle i
purchase those items if i actually have
already proven to myself that i'm doing
them so that way it's more of a reward
that makes me feel good rather than
something that brings about guilt number
17 is purses this one came about when i
actually had my kids because i found
that i was carrying around my diaper bag
everywhere and then i also wanted to
carry around my purse and it just it
wasn't really convenient so now i have
one small backpack purse and i actually
carry diapers in that thing but it's
also something that kind of looks
stylish at the same time so that i don't
look like i'm just carrying around a
diaper bag number 18 is alcohol this one
is because i never really was one that
really cared much for alcohol anyway and
recently i had purchased some moonshine
to try it out because i was in tennessee
they're well known for their moonshine
and i didn't like it and then i realized
why am i purchasing this item if it's
not my thing anyway if it's not really
my thing i don't see why i should spend
the money on it number 19 is more of a
broader category i've heard of the term
fast fashion i don't know if this would
be fast jewelry so i used to have all
sorts of different necklaces cheap
necklaces and bracelets and little
earring studs and things like that that
i would swap out for different outfits
and now i just don't really care about
all that anymore i have just a few
things as far as jewelry goes and i
don't really explore or purchase new
items number 20 is hair accessories i
find that for me my hair is most of the
time either in a tie in a clip or down
and i had all sorts of different
accessories that i never really used so
i got rid of those purchase teletize
these ties i find that keep my hair up
even though i have long hair and it
doesn't hurt my head it doesn't pull on
my hair i have one and my daughter has
one actually i stole hers today don't
tell her but otherwise i don't really
purchase any more hair accessories
number 21 is teeth whiteners oh my
goodness i cared so much about beauty
that i was willing to hurt myself for it
i had used teeth whiteners all the time
and my teeth would hurt i actually
damaged my enamel and now what i use is
coconut oil and baking soda you
basically mix it together and rub your
teeth with it like a toothpaste or oil
pulling oil pulling is basically where
you take coconut oil and you swish it
around your mouth and you do this every
single day for a while and then your
teeth actually get whiter i have done
this a few times and it works like magic
number 22 is one time clothing so if i
were to have some sort of an event where
i'm going to have to wear something that
i'm only going to wear for that one time
then i will now gear more towards
renting the item rather than purchasing
the item it can be much cheaper for you
even though you're spending money on an
item that you won't get to keep and
you're thinking oh that's such a waste
of money i might as well spend more
money and keep the item but you're gonna
keep the item take up more space and
you're not gonna use it so that's
definitely an option that i would
consider that may save you money in the
long run and space number 23 is
specialty cleaners you know like that
foaming toilet cleaner or that magic
degreaser i find that for me baking soda
vinegar and castol soap pretty much do
any cleaning job that i need number 24
is lunch when working this is actually
something that i used to do for years is
i would pack my lunch and take it to
work but now ever since i've heard of
intermittent fasting i have started too
fast when i'm working doing intermittent
fasting when i'm working means that i
don't have to prep a meal the day before
i don't have to pack it i don't have to
worry about having it cooled or heating
it up having to clean those containers
after i get back home and that time that
i would have spent eating i can either
spend it for myself or it's extra time
that i get to work so that i get to go
home earlier so for me it is a really
beneficial thing i don't ever buy lunch
when i'm working and lastly number 25 i
saved that controversial one for last it
is coffee shop coffees my husband and i
love a good cup of coffee but our
occasional visit to the coffee shop was
not the best use of our money i could
very well say that i removed coffee from
my life so that i could call myself a
minimalist but this is why i call it
controversial because i don't think that
minimalism is about just removing things
for the sake of removing them so that
you can say you own less i think it's
about removing excess removing those
things that either add burden or that
just don't necessarily add value to your
life so that you can make more room for
the things that do matter for those
things that do add joy and for me
drinking a latte is a very mindful
experience it brings me joy and comfort
and so it's not something that i want to
remove so instead of removing the coffee
we decided to buy an espresso machine so
that we never have to set foot in a
coffee shop again and truthfully i don't
even want to because
i think ours are better
so that is it for my 25 items that i no
longer buy i hope that this video has
been helpful for you if you enjoyed it
please give it a thumbs up and subscribe
so that you won't miss when i post a new
video i thank you so much for watching
and i can't wait to see you in the next
one bye for now